[Musique]
il aura fallu toute une journée de
préparatifs pour que la villa du
département se pare de fleurs
multicolores et de lumière pour
accueillir les festivités du nouvel an
tamoul au son de la musique
traditionnelle indienne les femmes
drapées de leurs saris cérémonial offre
des colliers de fleurs démarrent les aux
officiels de la soirée la fête se fait
au rythme de la musique et des danses
[Musique]
cette année c'est 5120 l'année sont pas
levés quant à lui vendu chambre et ça
c'est une année de transition à tous les
niveaux donc normalement je ne passe à
autre chose
cette année du changement on va dire
plutôt positive plutôt positif après
plusieurs années difficiles la maman
c'est une année des plus favorables et
avec des changements positifs des
ateliers de tressage de feuilles de coco
ou encore de henné montre le
savoir-faire de la communauté indienne
fière de ses valeurs et de sa culture
ado réunionnaise une forêt des mânes de
telles occasions nous rappelle également
l'harmonie religieuse et sociale la
compréhension mutuelle la compassion et
la paix entre les différentes
communautés pour lesquels la réunion aux
années 2000 une idée mal plus exemple
[Musique]
nos voeux les plus chaleureux de très
bonnes années vicari qu'elle soit
synonyme de bonheur de prospérité de
bien-être intérieur de tolérance et de
paix
des spectacles de danse qu'hollywood
animeront également cette soirée pour le
vicari 5120
[Musique]